- [Mark] All right.
- How long are you here for you here for,
you here for typically?
- [Mark] Typically like
today I'm just here for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But typically...
Typically I'm here from about
10:30 or 11 in the morning
until three or four or five.
- Okay.
- [Mark] And it kind
of depends on who's...
some days I come down here
and it's magic and it's like,
oh my God that was a great
one. That was a great one.
- Yeah, 'cause you get back to back
- [Mark] And other days I come down here,
and it's like that was a whole day wasted
with nothing I'm going to use.
I just throw out everything I sat through.
- And do you make money off YouTube?
- [Mark] Well, I just monetized
just a couple weeks ago
and I haven't made a penny yet,
but I'd really like to travel for this.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's my number one goal.
- Like in America or?
- [Mark] Just America I think,
'cause to travel all over the world would,
it gets so expensive and time consuming
that it would be hard
to do this. I'm one guy.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You see what my operation--
- [Mark] People will make
comments on YouTube and be like,
"tell your team to do this."
What fucking team?
(Hayden laughs)
You're looking at my team.
- The teams the guys that have the shirt.
- [Mark] Yeah, those guys
just want money from me,
so that's my team, so there is no team,
but if I started making money on YouTube
I would pay an editor.
I would pay somebody to help
me with the donation campaigns,
which is really ball, it's
the hardest part of what I do.
That's why I don't do a lot of them,
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because every time
I do one, I always regret it.
Every day that it's
active, except for Jerry.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What I'm doing for
Jerry right now. He's cool.
I could do a donation campaign
for guys like Jerry all day long.
- His name is Jerry? Jerry?
- [Mark] That's the guy
that got shot in the face.
- Oh, Jerry! I've seen him,
I think I've seen him once.
Yeah, I watched that one
too, that guy's amazing.
- [Mark] Yeah, he's an amazing
dude, and he's very likable.
- So at the Dream Center we have like
short term missioners come, so
people that come do a weekly,
I've led like teams of 50 going home,
and I'm like don't come
down here thinking that,
like it's all about them.
Like people sometimes
will teach you things,
and like tell you things where
you walk away and you're like
"wow, I think that person
did more for me than what,
like guys like Jerry.
You can see he's one of those guys,
like with the wizard in me,
he's just like, you know.
You're like, "wow."
- [Mark] Yeah, you think
you're going to save them.
- Yeah. No, he ends up saving
you, and you're like wow.
Yeah, definitely.
- [Mark] Yeah, no it's
interesting how all these dynamics
of human interaction are so interesting.
All right so, Hayden,
so you work at a place
called The Dream Center?
- [Hayden] Yes.
- [Mark] So you're from Australia?
- [Hayden] From Australia, Sydney, yeah.
- [Mark] And you're fairly new here.
You've been here how long?
- 15 months about, yeah,
so January of 2018.
- [Mark] And you're working
primarily with people
from Skid Row that are
fighting addiction issues?
- Yes, I've been coming to Skid Row,
like a couple of times a week
for over a year now, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me, like,
you've seen some of the
videos on my channel.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You contacted me
and that's why we're here,
but what have you learned
from your time with all these people?
- What have I learned?
- [Mark] I mean what is the
most misunderstood thing?
- That they're not people, so like,
these are people who were
babies were children,
who had a, you know, a
childhood, who had dreams,
who had goals and stuff and, you know,
give or take with what's
happened in their life,
they've had a few bad, you know,
some people have been
dealt a rougher, you know,
hand of cards, I guess you'd say,
on what their life has been themed,
but I think they're just,
yeah, they're people.
They grew up, you know,
people played sport,
they went to high school,
they did things like that,
so I think the thing is to forget,
because of the condition they can get in
or where they're at when you see them,
you forget that, hey,
this person wasn't here.
He hasn't been here his whole life.
So I think one thing is just
trying to find their story,
and whether they've been here
for one month or 10 years.
Find out what do you actually
want to do with your life
and how can we help them?
Or how are they going to get
out of here? Which I think is,
that's the big question
with the housing in LA
and the government and how it
all kind of works with that.
- [Mark] Have you seen successful stories
where people have--
- I've had people that I've prayed for
who have gotten housing,
and then with not a lot
of people having phones,
I haven't heard from
them, but I've just heard,
Hey, they left they got out of here
and they got housing and things like that.
So there are, as far
as successful stories,
I haven't been in touch with many,
because once they get out of here,
they kind of just disappear.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I've had a few like stray
phone calls from odd numbers,
which is people saying
that they got out of there
and they're in different
areas and stuff, but...
- [Mark] Yeah.
- There are, yeah, there
are success stories,
like it's not a lot.
It's not always all bad.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So what do you guys do?
You come down here and...
- Yeah, so we come down
Tuesday, Thursday, Friday night,
Saturday, and then Sunday,
and sometimes Wednesday, Friday mornings,
depending on how many people we have.
- [Mark] And what do you guys do?
- Basically The Dream Center is not,
we're not here to feed as
much as we're here to, like,
have conversations with these people
and with us being a
faith-based organization,
we're trying to help
people get out of here
and come to The Dream Center.
I think right now we have a
hundred and... might be 150.
We can house up to 150 men
in the men's discipleship program.
And in the women's one, I
think we can house up to
I'd say 40 or 50, something like that.
I'm not sure on the numbers,
but we're trying to get people
into the program that we have.
So the program we have
is a year long life recovery program,
so they come in, all their food,
clothing, you know, taken care of.
It's a residential live-in
program, so it's not a shelter.
It's not they come in, they sleep,
and then they can leave during the day.
They're there, they have a schedule.
- [Mark] And that's kind
of, that's part of the--
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It needs to be that way.
- It does because these people need
to get structure back in their lives?
Which I've me people here who probably
haven't had to answer
to anyone in 10 years.
- [Mark] I've heard from
several of the addicts
who've had some success in
the past but then relapse now,
but they even said that the only way
that rehab is ever going to work
is if I just commit to
a full year or more.
- Yeah, a full year. Yup, so our program,
once they do the year they
can apply for a second year,
and then they can apply for a third year,
so our program isn't
due the year and then,
you know, great job, like people--
- [Mark] And this is, what
does it cost, or is it free?
- Free! All free of cost.
First year, second year, third year,
so The Dream Center is a self-funded,
so it runs on donations.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- From other churches,
from people who donate
and things like that, but yeah.
I work in the program now,
so I do the first one to two weeks,
so when people coming in off the streets
and we have people coming in with
just the clothes that they're wearing
and they come in, you know,
they kind of have a week or two to detox
if they're coming off
alcohol, or crystal meth,
or heroin, or whatever.
Some guys just come in because,
you know, divorce is common,
like things like that.
So yeah, it's very common,
and then after the first two weeks
they move into an orientation phase,
which is four weeks, and then
basically the first month is
like easing them into
it and then after that
they start the real
phase which is level one,
which is three months, and
then level two, level three,
level four, and then they graduate, so.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And then they get their
job around The Dream Center,
so you could be in the kitchen,
you could be construction.
So it's giving them practical,
training them in how
to do practical stuff,
- [Mark] Something once they get out.
- Keeping them busy, you know,
it's actually teaching them a skill,
so once they do get
out of here, they said,
well for nine months I did
such and such, or yeah.
- [Mark] I've seen so many comments
on some of the addiction videos.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That I put on
my channel, that say,
"well, why don't you just
walk this person over to rehab
and get them all better,
and everything will be
perfect after that."
(Hayden laughing)
What would you say to that?
- That's called leading
the horse to the water
but you can't get it to drink.
- [Mark] I heard somebody
that is in your line of work,
say, I thought this was a
great thing, they said that--
- Yeah.
- [Mark] If an addict wants
to quit, nobody can stop them.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But if an addict
doesn't want to quit
nobody can make them.
- Nobody can make them.
- Yeah, exactly, and it's
like, guys will come in.
I didn't do the interview with them,
but straight after the
interview they come in,
and then, so I'm like the
first point of contact
with some guys, and I'm like,
"okay, so what brought you here?"
And they're like "my
mom made me come here,"
and I say, straight away,
I'm like, "if your mom made you come here,
you're not gonna change,
and this program's
going to be lot harder."
Like, you have to want to be here.
You can't come, you can't do rehab,
you can't get clean for
a spouse for, you know,
I think it's a driving
motive, it can drive you,
but at the end, it's
not going to be enough,
'cause when it gets
tough and when it gets,
when things stop coming up,
that you haven't worked through,
if you don't really want the
change, it's not going to work.
Like you can do it for your children,
which I think is amazing,
but they really need to
change for themselves
to be better for the children.
Not like so, as far as people wanting to,
yeah, I wish I could.
Some days I almost want to come in
and abduct people in a van
and just bring them in.
- [Mark] I know that's
almost like I talked a cop--
- And just come in the middle
of the night with a team.
- [Mark] I spoke to a
police officer yesterday
about a 51 50.
- Yeah. I've heard about that.
- [Mark] 'Cause I've been talking with
one of the guys I interviewed.
His name is Paul.
Blonde guy, white guy,
who's on crystal meth.
- Oh yeah, he had the
shirtless, and everything?
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And his mom reached out to me,
so I've be speaking with his mom,
and trying to find him,
trying to find him,
so this week I found him.
- Wow.
- [Mark] And I'm like,
"oh, this is great."
And she wants to put them up in a hotel
and then she's gonna fly
out and make him all better,
and it's all going to be great.
Except I saw him on the street and he,
you know, he trusts me, he's
been here several times, but.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I told him that I
was in contact with his mom
and he just thought that was odd.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I told him
that she'd like to help him,
and can I put you up in
a hotel or something,
so that his mom could hop on
a plane and come out here,
and he just started talking
some gibberish and walked off.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And it was very clear to me that
I don't think a pack of
wild horses could get him
to do anything,
- No, yeah.
- [Mark] Other than just
hang out in the street
and find his drug.
- Yeah, I think I read
a comment that you wrote
about people possibly getting arrested,
which is what I think about that as well.
- [Mark] Well, that's why I'm speaking
with the police officer
about a 51 50. I said what?
I mean, cause even Paul's
mom was suggesting that,
and he said you can't
really do that to people
unless they are clearly,
I mean, they're all hurting themselves,
but he says it's gotta be
like it's life-threatening.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And otherwise it won't stick.
- I'd say it's pretty
life-threatening down here, but yeah.
- [Mark] I know, but he
says it doesn't really work.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] The way you're thinking.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Where, "oh let's just
put them away and it'll all."
- 'Cause I've always had that, I'm like,
like for Chase, you know,
so heroin is the worst one
because people are scared to detox
and the detoxes are all full,
or at least the ones that
people tell me about.
So our program is straight cold turkey,
so it's no cigarettes, no alcohol.
It's nothing like, you can
have caffeine, that's about it.
So when I get anyone who wants
help, but they're on heroin,
they freak out and they can't do it.
I had to do it this week.
He was kicking heroin.
He did five days, you
know, irritated, angry,
cussing me out, all kinds of stuff,
and then we actually fully,
he actually kicked it,
but he wanted to go to another program,
but I was like, hey, if we
can help someone for six days,
that's fine, but people, yeah.
People have to want, you
have to want to do it,
and he will have, we all have free will.
So it is what it is, and
I really think people
have to really hit rock bottom for them
to want to get help.
Like something, which I dunno, like if...
You know how we see them out there,
you would think that's rock bottom,
so I don't know what
rock bottom is for them,
but people really have to hit rock bottom
and really get sick
and tired of, you know,
the tents moving, and the
cops messing with them, and,
you know, if it's a woman
most of the time they get him,
there's a man around here
that's messing with them
and owns them and stuff, but yeah.
- [Mark] What do you, and
certainly everyone's an individual
and they all have different stories.
Some people come from
backgrounds like yours and mine,
which is pretty straight,
but they end up addicted to crack or coke.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And other ones have
terrible traumatic childhoods
that they're trying to numb out from.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think the root cause
of a lot of these situations is.
- People trying to fill
something, so whether it's,
like you said, with people
even having good upbringings,
there's still something
there that they're missing.
So for them it could be, you know,
they might've had a normal
upbringing with two parents,
but they never felt love,
or they had parents who were too strict,
so they never got to do drugs,
so there's always that curiosity,
and then with the people
who've had terrible
upbringings, it just, yeah.
They're just trying to
numb the pain and forget
about things that have
happened, which is terrible,
'cause that's the common thing,
and then when you hear their upbringings
and it's just, it breaks
my heart and it's terrible.
It's just, you wouldn't
wish that upon anyone,
but with mental health
services and it's like,
I think there's a combination of two.
Mental health and drug addiction,
and either people will do
drugs without mental health
and then develop mental health,
or they'll have mental
health and then use drugs,
and then that's the one that creates
the mental health issues
and the drug addiction
is what really, I think that's when people
that's when I don't even know to, yeah.
- [Mark] I could title
every video on my channel
mentally ill person.
- Yeah, mentally ill, yeah.
- [Mark] Because that applies
to every single one of them,
but that would get redundant and boring,
and I don't think I'd get that many people
coming to my channel.
So I title it, you know,
crystal meth addict,
or prostitute, or pimp, or whatever,
but it all boils down to
some mental health issue,
doesn't it?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I mean I think
what I keep hearing
over and over and over again is
it's a lack of unconditional
love as a child.
- Yeah. Mhmm, yeah.
- [Mark] 'Cause what a
lot of people call love,
like from a parent, actually
wasn't unconditional love.
- No.
- [Mark] So it's almost something
that's disguised as that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you think that's
love, but it actually wasn't.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that's almost
worse than not having it at all.
- Yeah, mhmm.
- [Mark] And that's how I
hear a lot of these stories,
and I'm like, man, you came from
what sounds like a good childhood.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But that integral part of--
- Yeah, if you dig a little
deeper, it'd be like,
it looks good on paper.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know, two parents and middle-class,
but almost that can sometimes
almost be the worst one
because there's no, like...
- [Mark] It's not clear.
- There's no connection
with, you know what I mean?
Like the parents might be busy with work
and the kids just never
feel like they're being
any kind of relationship
with their parents,
and it's funny that you
say unconditional love
because that's something
that I'm trying to work on
right now with people.
I really struggle with, I come down here
and I can love on these
people, go inside tents,
sit inside tents, you know,
talk to people for 45 minutes,
but then sometimes with people
in my own circle I struggle
because they're not, you know
what I mean? It's like, yeah.
- [Mark] I think every single human.
- Unconditional love is,
man, it's a hard thing,
and I'd say, yeah, trauma, so
whether it's a minor trauma
from something like that,
or trauma from, you know,
being sexually abused or things like that.
- [Mark] Or being bullied in school.
- Yeah, bullying. Yeah,
with Ronnie, I know Ronnie.
Brooke, who's like one of my best friends,
who I was just with before I came down.
She's in contact with Ronnie's
mom and all kinds of stuff,
so we're trying to sort that out
because she legitimately
sees Ronnie and she's like,
like I could be friends with this girl.
Like I could be, not just
I met her and it's like,
wow, she's amazing.
Like I see her being like a part of my,
like helping her out of this--
- [Mark] There's a billion
comments like that.
- Ronnie's an amazing person.
- [Mark] I can't put
these viewers in contact,
'cause eventually somebody
is going to be a stalker.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that gets
somebody into trouble.
I don't want any part of that.
- Yeah, so it's mainly just, yeah.
Minor, it could be minor
trauma or major trauma,
but there's some kind of thing that people
have never dealt with, so
they're trying to fulfill it
or satisfy themselves
in drugs or prostitution
and cause that's, you know,
acceptance of other people,
whatever it is, but I think
it's all just trauma, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, I mean,
people look at my channel,
and think, oh, it's an
addiction Skid Row channel,
and it clearly is, to me it's
not, and over the next year
it'll become very clear that it's not.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But if anything,
what I'm doing is an
unconditional love channel.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because to me that's exactly,
that's what these stories are all about.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] The lack of that sends a person,
like, just off the rails.
- Yeah, it does, yeah.
- [Mark] So what's your background?
You came from Australia?
- Came from, so grew up
in Sydney, Australia.
- [Mark] Your family was together?
- Yeah, together, yeah.
I grew up, my parents are still together.
They just celebrated 30 years last week.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
Middle child, I got two
sisters, which was just great.
I love them. (laughing)
You know, me against
the world being the boy
and the middle child, but yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, there's
always a special dynamic.
- Yeah, then we lived in
Australia till we were 10.
Then we moved to Atlanta,
Georgia for three years.
Then we moved here to L.A. for two years
and then moved back to Australia in 2009,
and then I came back out
here in January, 2019,
to help out at The Dream Center,
because when we lived in L.A.
2007, 2008, we were involved.
So it was something that had
a pretty big impact on my family,
and when my life went off
the rails a little bit
I knew that was a place I could come back,
because I need to get out of,
I was done with Australia.
I just gotta get out of here,
kinda throw the smoke bombs and disappear,
which has been for a little
bit longer than what I thought.
- [Mark] So you have a history
of some issues as well?
- Yeah, I had some like
mental health issues, 2018.
I got diagnosed with like
depression and was kind of
having suicidal thoughts and tendencies
for a good six months,
which we only just met, but
I'm a very out there person,
so for somebody who'd
never dealt with feelings
of low before, like I didn't know,
it was almost like extreme
because I didn't know how to deal with it,
'cause I'm such a person
that's usually high and up
and always having a good time and joyous,
and then when realize that
people are expecting you
to be like that, it kind of,
and working in the industry I was working,
I was a personal trainer,
so no one wants a
depressed personal trainer.
- [Mark] (laughing) No.
- They want somebody who's
going to encourage them,
so, you know, I had to put...
It was very like draining
trying to put on an act
for those six months and then yeah.
Realized I had to come back.
- [Mark] What do you think the
culprit was in your problem?
- Well, I had all my
eggs all in one basket,
so I was what I thought was
my purpose and, you know,
my calling or whatever I
was going to do in life
was all gone. Once that got ripped away,
I had no backup plan, and
then, yeah, I'd say that.
I would say having what
I thought my dream was
kind of ripped out from
underneath me, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, well I
think helping others...
- Perspective.
- [Mark] Giving to others.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Has some kind of
magical effect on a person.
- Yeah, like our pastor, Matthew Barnett,
the pastor of The Dream
Center always says,
"if you're in a rut or
you're feeling, you know,
depressed and down and he's
like go and serve others."
And it'll bring you, it's
not like a quick fit,
like meant to heal it, but
you'll just realize that
helping people who are in
a worse situation than you,
which is like what happened for me.
The first time I came
down here, I was like,
"whoa, my life's not that bad."
I lived in a house my whole life.
I had two parents who
were awesome, you know.
I've got food, I've got
clothes, I've got this,
and you know, I met a dude
named, do you know Bart?
Young, white dude who
stays across from Whitney.
He's always riding
around and riding a bike.
He's got blonde hair.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- He was the first dude I met,
and he's a year older than me.
And I was just like, "what
are you doing down here?"
And he was like, he
couldn't even answer it.
I don't think anyone had asked him
what he was doing down
here, and he was like,
"I don't know," and that just
blew me away, and I was like--
- [Mark] I think the tendency to be
a little like self
conscious, self obsessed--
- Yeah.
- [Mark] All that kind
of stuff, that a lot of,
you see in regular society all the time.
Who's the comedian on
"Saturday Night Live"?
She does the Sarah Palin.
- Oh, Tina Fey.
- [Mark] Tina Fey, made a comment once,
I thought was great about this.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And she says,
Mother Teresa never worries
about her thighs touching.
- Ah, yeah.
- [Mark] You know, she's
always helping people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And she feels
great about herself,
regardless of how she's looking that day
or how her skin or hair or whatever looks,
and I think there's a
lot of truth in that.
- Yeah, definitely.
Like, I think you come
in here and you realize
how much you actually
do have without knowing,
like, it's almost like,
it really threw me off,
'cause I was like, wow.
I just feel like a real
sense of conviction
of feeling ungrateful for my life.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And this is like Skid
Row, and then, you know,
I haven't been to third world
countries, but this is...
- [Mark] I mean, gratitude
is a hard thing to just,
you know, everybody says,
"Oh, we should have our gratitude."
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That sounds good on paper,
but how do you actually do it?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I found by, you know,
I believe I'm helping somebody.
- Yeah. Oh, yeah.
- [Mark] And I've heard
it a thousand times,
but I also heard that
I'm exploiting people
and all this other
stuff, which I don't buy,
but there's some truth in that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You know, when...
(Mark sighs)
How do you, I mean,
what's the best analogy.
When a wealthy man...
When an attractive female
marries a wealthy man
is she doing it because of
this security he'll provide,
or is it because it's true love?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] There's probably
a little bit of both.
- A bit of both, yeah.
- [Mark] And when a man buys
an expensive sports car,
is it because he
appreciates fine automobiles
or is it because he feels insecure?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's a little bit of both.
It's always a little bit of both.
And so am I exploiting people?
Yes, of course I'm exploiting people,
but every single person I
didn't coerce, or trick,
or manipulate them into coming in.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I said, would
you like to do this?
And very often I even forget to mention
that there's money involved.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then they
find out that there is,
and, "Oh, that's great. I didn't
realize we would get paid."
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And so on the one hand, yes,
I'm sure if you look at it
negatively I'm exploiting them,
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But in a positive light
I think I'm helping them to unload a lot
of their hidden closeted garbage that...
- Yeah, it just unravels, yeah.
- [Mark] They're wearing it
every day of their lives.
And I've heard from several
people that I've talked to
that said they've stopped using
since they had to talk in front of me.
- That's amazing.
- [Mark] So that's interesting,
but I'm not saying I'm healing anything.
I think just unloading their...
- It's always like as much as you want,
I think like as much as
you want someone to hear,
you know, what's your story.
You don't think these
people want, you know,
people to know their story and
know how their day is going.
I think it's just like,
that's where, 'cause I know
we don't have a lot of
homeless people in Australia.
And then, so my mindset was
kind of stereotype based
when I came here and then I just realized,
and I was like, they're just people.
Flesh, bone, you know, they're human.
They're exactly the same as me.
They check out, and it's just like,
you know, they have feelings.
I'm sure they know that,
yeah, they're here, and
just hearing that, yeah.
I would just encourage, like
go talk to a homeless person.
Go find their story and
find what they need.
Just give you a good sense of, yeah,
where you're at and what you have,
and then you'd probably
cherish it a little bit more
and walk around with a little
more sense of gratitude,
I'd say.
- [Mark] Yeah, I've never been happier
since I started doing this.
- Yeah. This like, healed my...
You know, because I'm helping people,
because I just realized that,
hey, my life's pretty good,
and like depression.
I can be in the worst mood
and I come down here and I'm like, wow.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's not so much
that I'm comparing my life to
their poor miserable lives,
but there's something about what I'm doing
that makes me feel better about myself
and that bleeds into
every aspect of my life.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] From the way
I sleep to everything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] You just stand up straighter,
you feel better about yourself.
- Yeah, you can go to bed knowing that,
hey, I kind of helped.
I did something today that
helped someone, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, I didn't just--
- [Mark] Yeah, I've had countless people.
I've talked to, I think 1300 people now.
- Wow. 1300, wow.
- [Mark] And I can't count
how many people have come back
and said, "Oh my God, that was so great.
I want to do that again."
- Wow.
- [Mark] They almost all do that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Almost everybody I speak to,
if I see them again, like "can
I do that again?" (chuckles)
- That's amazing.
- [Mark] And it's like,
so I think there's something
very therapeutic about...
- Yeah, definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] Getting your stuff
out in the light of day
letting everybody hear it, at
least in theory, on YouTube
you're talking to the entire
planet, in theory. Right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And there's something
very powerful in that.
- Definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] And it frees you up to it to...
It keeps you from being
locked into doing the same
defensive mechanism behaviors
that you've always done.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're free to do
otherwise, if you choose to.
It just takes a little
bit of courage to do that.
- Yeah, it does, yeah. It
does take a big of courage
to go walk up to, 'cause
I remember I was scared
of homeless people as a kid.
We went to New York City
once, and you know--
- [Mark] Well, I'm not saying, no,
courage is not an issue for me,
but courage for them
to unload these things.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry.
- [Mark] That's what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, definitely.
- [Mark] I mean, it takes a lot
of courage for these people.
- Yeah, because you'll
get people who will ask,
"Hey, what's your story?" and I see it.
And I can see the, you can
say them trying to process it
of like, oh no I can't bring that up
or I don't trust this
person and then, you know,
I might be times where I've come down
and then it might be the
fourth time that person
finally opens up, and then
we're able to actually be like,
okay, you know, now we can help.
What do you need? You need
shoes or you need this?
We have the program we have, you know,
it's just until they yeah, you know.
Until they open up and they
want the help it's kind of,
it's the same with addiction
or whether I need services or whatever.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think what
The Dream Center is providing
is, it's what every
person down here needs,
but they also have to want it.
- [Hayden] Yeah, they
have to want it, yeah.
- [Mark] All right, Hayden,
well, thank you so much for talking to me.
- [Hayden] Thank you.
- [Mark] And good luck with
everything you're doing.
I'm proud of you.
- [Hayden] Yeah, thank you man.
The world needs more people like you.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- [Mark] All right, thank you.
- [Hayden] Wow.
- [Mark] That was cool.
- [Hayden] Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're wearing
the right color shirt
for my background.
- [Hayden] Oh, yeah!
- [Mark] (laughing) It was perfect.
Couldn't have done better.
- [Hayden] I don't have many shirts,
half my wardrobe is...